Star Wars has been around for decades so
it's a sad but inevitable reality that
many of the actors who have appeared in
that galaxy far far away are no longer
with us here are a few paces from the
franchise you may not have realized
passed away Admiral Ackbar had a pretty
small role in the original Star Wars
trilogy in fact he only appeared briefly
in Return of the Jedi even still the
character's appearance made him a firm
fan favorite as did the iconic line that
has now passed into pop-culture legend
naturally then fans of Star Wars mourn
the unfortunate passing of Akbar's voice
actor Erik Bauer spelled who died in
2016 at the age of 93 interestingly
Bauer spelled once argued that he
thought of his movie roles as a
secondary career that he had
accidentally stumbled into as opposed to
his more solid work as a radio producer
he once wrote the voice work I did in
movies was accidental I was working with
Randy Tom on radio dramas at his
technical quarters at Lucasville one day
Ben Burtt sound designer for Star Wars
came by and asked if I were to audition
for a voice in the movie Bowers Feld
also voiced bib Fortuna one of Jabba the
Hutt's associates and he returned to the
role of Admiral Ackbar in the force
awakens which released just months
before he passed away as he dies in the
opening hour of the film
uncle Owen can be considered a pretty
minor Star Wars character in the grand
scheme of things but his death is the
primary call to arms that sets Luke
Skywalker off on his hero's journey so
in a weird way
Owen is actually one of the movie's most
important characters making actor Phil
Brown one of the stories pivotal players
sadly Brown passed away in 2006 at the
age of 89 even though he was well known
when Star Wars was made he'd face plenty
of hardships as an actor in the 1950s
Brown was caught up in Senator Joseph
McCarthy's communist trials and was
actually blacklisted because he refused
to comply with the house on American
Activities committee's demand to name
communists in Hollywood he denied being
a communist himself but was still forced
to move to London to continue acting as
it happened George Lucas was filming in
London at the same time and needed a
local actor with an American accent so
he brought Brown on board
not long after Brown was with Lucas and
Tunisia filming a New Hope's early
scenes on Tatooine
a powerhouse English actress Sheila
Fraser died in 2000 at the age of 79 gia
Blade a small but memorable role in a
new hope as Luke's aunt Beru the
character dies early on in the story so
Fraser was unable to contribute a lot to
the film but just like Lars Peru's death
sparse Luke into action driving his
character arc through much of the
trilogy and even though her role in Star
Wars is small somewhat argue that she's
indirectly responsible for Luke becoming
the hero he is at a New York Comic Con
panel author Meg Cabot argued that
Barrie case suggesting that aunt Peru's
kindness and caring for Luke helped him
overcome the dark side and defeat the
Empire it also helped him find the
compassion to look for the good left in
Darth Vader without whom he never would
have stopped Emperor Palpatine so yeah
nice work and Peru drew Henley appeared
in the Star Wars franchise as red leader
the pilot who led Luke's squadron in the
strike against the Death Star at the
climax of a new hope sadly he was
accidentally credited as drew Henley at
the end of the film but hey he at least
managed to squeeze in a post-mortem
appearance and wrote one thanks to the
power of archived footage in the first
film red leader actually nearly destroys
the Death Star he launches his torpedoes
at the exhaust port but his aim is
slightly off not long after his mess his
ship is destroyed and the poor guy is
subsequently killed Henley was a
well-respected actor when he was cast in
a new hope but was forced to retire not
long after the film was released due to
his struggles with bipolar disorder
after working through his mental illness
he settled down to run a
bed-and-breakfast with his wife Henley
died in 2016 at the age of 75 Anakin
Skywalker has been played by multiple
actors across the Star Wars franchise
but when his deformed weary face is
revealed in Star Wars Return of the Jedi
that's classically trained actor
sebastian shaw playing the role he also
portrayed Anakin's force ghost at the
end of the original version of Return of
the Jedi before being replaced by Hayden
Christensen and subsequent releases Shaw
was mostly known as a stage actor
outside of Star Wars fandom he was a
member of the Royal Shakespeare Company
where he'd often played lead or featured
roles he was also a Broadway veteran and
was well known for taking on parts and
daring and controversial plays Lucas
choosing to digitally replace sha with
Christensen and Return of the Jedi
sparked some controversy at the time but
Star Wars fans will still
forget the reveal of Darth Vader's face
Shaw passed away in 1994 at the age of
89 jason wingreen didn't actually appear
in the Star Wars films in person but his
voice brought one of the sagas most
iconic villains to life when Green was
the original voice of Boba Fett the
intergalactic bounty hunter who tracks
down Han Solo during the Empire Strikes
Back
when Green was also a well known
television actor Winnie auditioned for
Star Wars having appeared in a number of
different shows throughout the 60s 70s
and 80s he originally auditioned for the
role of Yoda but lost out on the role
and was cast as Boba Fett's dead and
only recorded four lines for the final
film
he's not even credited and it wasn't
until the year 2000 that the public
discovered who had voiced the villain
still it's a testament to win Green's
talent that Boba Fett became such a
massively popular character nonetheless
when green passed away in 2016 at the
age of 95 you may never have seen Kenny
Baker space or heard his voice in a Star
Wars film but it's a fair bet you still
know who he is for most of the movies in
the franchise he portrayed one of Syfy's
most iconic characters r2d2 r2d2 wasn't
a puppet or an animatronic like so many
other creatures in the Star Wars
universe instead there was an actor
inside that droid Baker was only 3 foot
8 inches so he could fit inside the
chassis used for filming and he's the
one responsible for crafting much of
r2d2 personality when Baker passed away
in 2016 at the age of 81 starwars.com
wrote whether it was the slow turn of
Artoo's dome to convey suspicion or
nervous wobble signifying fear Baker
made a robotic beam seem very human
while Baker played the droid in all
three original films and two prequels he
also played an Ewok and Return of the
Jedi Peter Cushing was a massive star
when he was cast as grand moff tarkin in
a new hope he also brought an immediate
gravitas to the film losing menace and
calm and somehow coming off every bit as
intimidating as Darth Vader himself
charming to the last before appearing in
a new hope Cushing was an icon in horror
cinema he appeared in many of the
Dracula and Frankenstein films of the
50s and 60s and also portrayed Sherlock
Holmes in a few movie adaptations after
a long and illustrious career Cushing
passed away in 1994 at the age of 81
despite this however he
technically reprise his role as Tarkin
and rogue one a Star Wars story even
though the film came out over 20 years
after his death Cushing was recreated in
the film with state-of-the-art CGI
nearly climbing out of the uncanny
valley in the process nearly even though
obi-wan Kenobi died in a new hope Alec
Guinness appeared in the other films of
the original trilogy thanks to the power
of the force his casting lend some
credibility to the original film but he
also infamously viewed the story as in
his words fairytale rubbish Guinness was
a hugely famous actor when he signed on
for George Lucas's space opera he'd won
an Oscar for The Bridge on the River
Kwai and had starting classics such as
Lawrence of Arabia and Doctor Zhivago
and while many of the leading actors and
star wars are big names now they weren't
at the time making Guinness by far the
biggest star in the movie in 1977 but
why did he join the project if he hated
the material well there are a couple of
reasons first he thought the moral of
the story was admirable enough second he
wouldn't have to do any publicity for
the film and third the studio offered
him a massive salary of course he
ignored any fan mail he received about
Star Wars and hated discussing his role
as obi-wan Sir Alec Guinness passed away
in the year 2000 at the age of 86 one of
the most prolific actors in the Star
Wars franchise Christopher Lee's career
spans over 250 roles over the length of
his career Lee is absolutely one of the
gods of geekdom and his grace to several
of Hollywood's most notable franchises
here he portrayed Count Dooku in two of
the prequel films attack of the clones
and Revenge of the Sith Lee became a
star due to his many appearances in the
Hammer horror Dracula franchise where
funnily enough he frequently
collaborated with another Star Wars alum
Peter Cushing Lee's imposing figure and
commanding voice made him perfectly
suited to play the villain which helped
him a great deal and arguably his
biggest ever film role playing Saruman
in the Lord of the Rings a man of many
talents Christopher Lee also released a
number of heavy metal albums when he was
in his 80s and 90s he was also knighted
served in the Second World War as a
member of the RAF and was attached to
the British Army's long range desert
group the precursor of the modern-day
SAS he passed away in 2015 at the age of
93
despite never having shown his face on
screen at Star Wars Peter Mayhew quickly
became one of the sagas most iconic
characters his performance as Chewbacca
helped bring a sense of real humanity to
a character where many other actors
could have easily been lost beneath the
mask Mayhew was a hospital orderly when
he auditioned for Chewbacca and even
kept that job until after Return of the
Jedi was released the seven foot three
inch actor then essentially made his
living off the role for the rest of his
life attending conventions as a fan
favorite star for decades
he eventually reprised the role in
2015's the force awakens nearly everyone
who worked with Mayhew on the Star Wars
franchise had nothing but kind things to
say about it after his death in April
2009 teen Mark Hamill wrote on Twitter
he was the gentlest of giants a big man
with an even bigger heart who never
failed to make me smile and a loyal
friend who I loved dearly I'm grateful
for the memories we shared and I'm a
better man for just having known him
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]